thank you
[Applause]
breakfast
be all right
[Applause]
professionals
[Music]
one more time
[Applause]
[Music]
give me one second
for all of us and we love the action
they take it and of course I'm doing the
show for Korean I'm very excited about
it talk to me about later on this
evening how are you going to
how do I feel look walking everybody's
looking at me
yes but they're very different in a
cocktail party very different
as like a runaway you know like people
looking at me I'm used to it but one
once we're actually doing a show here in
the big event like that it feels a
little bit oh my God my heart is like
also talks about tonight
oh my God
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
this way
[Music]
oh yeah she gives me that vibe
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
for you
got here from Saudi Arabia two nights
ago
and I absolutely love France I love
candy so I'm still a good friend
hopefully gonna make some new friends
too
excuse me
[Music]
I should probably everybody's squatting
here
thank you thank you
[Music]
all right excuse me
an hour
ago
first very early
for a minute
Gareth is out in the cop town
excuse me excuse me
[Music]
one hour
thank you
together
[Music]
without you
truth
um
[Music]
come on
remember
they have their nipples out tonight yeah
[Music]
blood right now
all right there's two models
[Applause]
[Music]
they're all together
start
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
together
[Applause]
the singing
stupid questions
[Applause]
[Music]
happy to be here again
what's going on so I'm very very curious
and look forward to the
um
[Music]
it's a dream come true it's one of them
that's for sure definitely amazing thank
you so much
enjoy this evening thank you very much
tonight
[Applause]
because I love supporting amphar I know
what's happening
yeah
how are you really good I'm so excited
to talk to you because
I found out like last year that I got
like the same gym that you had no way
that's amazing yes
yeah exactly have you had any people
reaching out to you about it yes I mean
this is the best part of it you know
like social media everybody is like
criticizing social media and I can't
stretch enough how you know powerful
actually social media if we use them in
the right way are because just by
sharing my story of my genetic mutation
Baraka one
um so many women wrote to me that
actually they didn't even know about the
existence of the jeans and they had like
the mom the aunt died because of breast
cancer and nobody even told them about
the genetic mutation so a lot of girls
actually wrote me they went to have
their tests done and they're gonna have
the you know they they're gonna take the
decision whatever decision they decide
to make but at least they are informed
because I had no idea and I have
education I am well traveled you know
what I mean and I still didn't know like
I went to check my breasts because I
found something and then the hospital
asked me like what's your family history
and I said well my aunt died at my age
of breast cancer and they immediately
they sent me to do the genetic testing
you know but I had no idea I could have
done it like 10 years earlier you know
so it's just amazing yeah the power of
sharing I always say I'm gonna have to
email you because I know you put the
email yeah you will get an email from me
I love it actually you know I love that
it's kind of overwhelming because a lot
of people write me and they really hate
to not answering to everybody but I win
the so many inspiring things that they
just push me to keep sharing because
sharing is like so powerful I actually
read a lot of biographies as well like
inspiring stories because you know just
knowing that somebody else went through
the same you know hardships as you and
they made it through it's amazing now
it's the most powerful thing it gives
you the strength you're like I can do it
too and if you cannot if you could
auction for anything like a dinner with
a celebrity who would you like being for
oh dinner with a celebrity I have no
crushes like that so I guess I would bid
on the clothes you know which I'm
actually today I'm I have the honor you
know to walk the show the Karin show you
know we're auctioning the the clothes
you know so I guess you know if I had
those Millions I would definitely buy
myself the clothes well thank you so
much thank you so much
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
um
[Music]
any interest here
I'm glad we got her back sorry about
that don't worry
don't worry about it
oh settings
it's important because okay and we have
a good job a very nice dress but it's a
charity event and I think right here
thank you
all right
[Music]
thank you
today
once again
[Applause]
[Music]
over here
[Applause]
oh you're right
together
all right
thank you so much
it is it is
[Music]
um
okay
thank you
[Applause]
guys myself
foreign
[Music]
thank you
this way please
watch it
again
[Music]
excuse me
[Applause]
anything coming up of interest
and the dinner starts at eight right
excuse me
[Music]
[Applause]
exclusively
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah baby
tonight
in the first place
[Music]
[Applause]
excuse me
yeah you can be together
[Applause]
well well thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
such a beautiful challenge
[Applause]
[Music]
um I wanted to be here tonight because I
think it's such a beautiful charity and
um just to be able to do what I can
which is perform and bring people
together and hopefully we can raise a
ton of money tonight so I'm I'm just
here because I really love what the
charity does and um hopefully we'll just
raise a lot of coins and you're on the
same bill as Gladys Knight oh my gosh so
incredible I mean when they told me
Gladys Knight was also performing I was
like oh my God
tonight that's what I'm excited about
oh yeah we were just talking about Tina
Turner I mean what um so sad but what
did we we're celebrating her music
yesterday actually we're playing all her
you know her best hits and I was just
saying how she's been so inspirational
to me because she's had such a long
running career but she's also had a lot
of success in her later age as well and
I think that's as a woman that's a
really inspiring thing because for women
you know as we get older we start you
know becoming less sexy but she she
broke all those
I don't want to curse but all that
you know so
um yeah we'll be honoring her tonight as
well hopefully thank you
oh because
I don't speak the best English Okay
English only
how did you go to be part of tonight as
a performer like what do you think when
they go in touch with you um I've always
been I've always watched you know the
obviously it's such a great cause but
I've always watch the performances in
the red carpets and what it stands for
so to be here tonight is honest honestly
an honor so I'm just happy to be here
and happy to support the best way that I
can which is through music and there's
going to be auctions today if you could
pick I know if you could bid for an
auction for a dinner with anybody
if I could bid for an auction with a
dinner of Beyonce I would give my uh I
would give everything I ever made and I
would give all my guts I'm just kidding
what are you gonna perform tonight I'm
performing I'm good of course and uh in
the Name of Love
thank you thank you so much
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
I think
foreign
[Applause]
good morning
down
[Music]
so it's amazing
Universe yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
people
I'll tell you when you can see it she's
too much
you guys move sorry can you move please
[Music]
um
[Laughter]
[Applause]
depressed
[Music]
thank you perfect thank you so much
thank you thank you
[Applause]
excuse me
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
okay guys
[Applause]
[Music]
are you sure
[Applause]
[Music]
two years
well I've been supporting ampa for many
many many years obviously
[Music]
and that's why we're still trying
um but I think we're on the right path
so let's keep on going definitely it
also tonight's a celebration of music
and also Adam Lambert yeah I'm friends
with him I love him he's so amazing so
yes it will be amazing amazing thank you
so much
um
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Music]
all right
well they're all new hands maybe but
that doesn't really mean anything
you want Rebels too right yes
[Music]
all right
now
[Applause]
all right
guys
[Applause]
[Music]
amazing
excuse me
thank you it's great to hear this my
second time
in the charity options happen and you
see like people you know donating lots
of money and um it's really awesome
festival and this is
just a fun week here celebrating
[Applause]
I love it
please
[Applause]
I think if they walk away
it's obviously doing it
um
[Applause]
I mean it's extremely important so much
of my work is kind of based in
representing marginalized communities or
you know
no absolutely I mean it's really
incredible I live in Los Angeles and um
I have a ton of friends who are out and
have more and more in recent years
become more transparent about their
diagnosis and how they're navigating
life you know as young people are dating
in L.A
um
[Music]
connotation that it used to when there's
a greater acceptance and conversation
around it so I think that's a huge part
definitely
[Music]
yeah
as an artist who kind of straddles the
line between pop and alternative she's
definitely like one of the original
icons of the world bringing a really
yeah
um
singing in the skies for all of us and
for yeah
[Applause]
so beautiful
Eva Longoria
[Music]
[Applause]
excuse me thank you foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
all right
guys
excuse me excuse me
happy birthday
[Applause]
I don't forget you should say welcome
thank you
[Music]
excuse me oh and Adam Lambert excuse me
exactly
which doesn't hurt much easier
um
[Applause]
but they are falling down
okay I'm getting wheels anyway sounds
good
I was like bend down
it's a house
um
[Music]
locations
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
another one
yeah
[Music]
well
it's great
[Music]
she's right there
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
services
thank you
amazing good to go welcome to ampa does
it feel nice to be here this evening it
feels wonderful to be here I was here in
2017 for the con one and
um about two years ago I received a
wonderful award around Los Angeles
has a very special place absolutely and
I think it's a really important cause
and one that we need to keep shining
light on especially so many other things
going on in the world
should seem to forget that this is still
a very important
[Applause]
tonight we are going to celebrate but
also music as well as something that we
should remember
absolutely I mean she is the epitome of
strength endurance I mean she's an icon
okay
her life story with us
about this wonderful outfit talk me
through this this is pretty
extraordinary well thank you you I
thought since we are raising money
tonight with the fashion show I thought
I would try to encourage people to spend
money
okay
welcome to Amazon
[Applause]
[Music]
I am even better that you're here it's
lovely to see you thank you I'm really
good
gratitude this is my day job no it is
I'm so lucky and I've been blessed so
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
um
all right
here
questions
thank you
tomorrow
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
oh my god it feels so amazing
um I usually come some years but this
year's most exciting because I have a
reason to be here you know what I'm
saying so um yeah just been enjoying it
I mean you're supporting the Empire
tonight yes well I usually come every
year and I think I missed last year and
I'm like no I'm not missing everything
you know
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
every year
parties
did I tell you it was like every single
day something on my way here I was on
zooms and I'm like I'm not missing here
what's it like walking this carpet with
your children well
um this is actually my first time uh at
can at the festival and first time at an
Empire event here obviously so uh I
didn't know exactly what to expect but
it's been really special
um screened the film Wes Anderson's film
here asteroids asteroid City and I've
never experienced the type of
uh genuine appreciation for storytelling
and for filmmaking that uh that I felt
when we walked into that Cinema it was
and I'm and I'm so pleased that they
were there to understand yes there's
glamor and there's the circus but it's
really about art it's really about the
work and here tonight it's about uh you
know an extraordinarily important cause
but also one that amfar has been uh
seriously and measurably impactful in uh
in helping to solve so yeah it's pretty
good all around yeah and what's it like
you feel your sort of the permanent part
of Wes Anderson's sort of world now you
know as long as you don't have me as
long as you'll put up with me yeah I'll
uh I'll uh I'll be there to work for him
he's a he's a singular director
um he's a singular Vision a singular way
of working and uh and I love it I love
it I love working with him I think he's
a genius
[Applause]
[Music]
nothing sick oh yes
well
he's ready
[Music]
[Applause]
for me
we're having a nice adult trip hopefully
so I was lucky enough to perform here
years ago and make friends with
everybody and we try to come back every
year I'd like to see music yes
[Music]
I was lucky enough to get to see her
perform years ago in person so one of my
favorite performers ever we will miss
you terribly team and tonight I come to
only Gladys Knight performing yes I know
Gladys very well uh we love Gladys so
we're very excited to see her tonight
hello and welcome to Amazon perfect
thank you so much
oh well yes we we have uh we have uh
three kids that we left at home for this
trip so we could have a little adult fun
in the south of France so we're happy to
be here for such a great cause and see
so many of our friends from over the
years how do we erase the stigma around
HIV and AIDS well I mean I think it's
just about uh you know transparency and
it's about a collective
um Community working towards uh
achieving the goal that we want which is
to eradicate it completely and I heard
you just mentioned Tina Turner yes the
huge fans one of the greatest performers
to ever grace the stage and has inspired
me many times throughout the years
oh no uh not probably not this might be
a little above my price range but
yeah if there's a Happy Meal Maybe
please
[Applause]
um
[Music]
Clara
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
I see that bag
great
[Applause]
[Music]
physically impossible
[Applause]
it's impossible he needs to go away
peace
[Applause]
[Music]
tell me
[Applause]
this way
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
this evening
[Music]
thank you
okay excuse me please
excuse me
oh do you think that two mats that lady
see you next time
my little face
excuse me excuse me
[Music]
they know of me they know we're here
thank you
that's nice
[Music]
[Applause]
but there we go
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
guys
I just dropped it it might be me yeah
respond
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
all right guys
[Applause]
um
[Music]
oh yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
this way
[Applause]
thank you
yeah
over there right thank you
surprise
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
directions
thank you
hello everybody
fantastic welcome to amphar thank you
very much what does it feel like to be
here it's amazing it's my first time
here so lovely to come and support the
cars and and uh see all the lovely boats
coming by and experience the the
everything special about Ken how
important do you think an event like
foreign
bowling and I think it does great things
I think their efforts have been
astounding over the years and and every
year it gets feels like gets bigger and
bigger I say that having not been here
but uh but um yeah I feel like it's very
powerful absolutely and also we've got
some Legends performing tonight
particularly are you looking forward oh
my goodness let's see I had no I didn't
know the surprises so I'm very very
excited about that I'm a huge fan of
them amazing can I get mistakes
thank you
they wanted to pre-approve the questions
Christina
um
how it ended
up
tell her to take some videos
thank you
excuse me
um no I think I'm okay yeah thank you
okay
I'm not sure to come and figure it out
yeah it's okay yeah okay thank you
are you home what do you want yeah
thank you
photographers are quiet
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
hey everybody
back to your library
thank you
um
[Music]
oh yeah
it's big
big like
again
with me
I thought it was gonna be cold
okay okay
yes
oh
yeah I feel comfortable when you sit
down the stuff
[Music]
this will be the beginning
I don't know
they say she's enough car
s
and why didn't Queens stay in this hotel
[Laughter]
so I think
excuse me
so you can eat it
did you hear that
um
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
Ed Westwick is such a random robot
oh my God right sorry
Gossip Girl
because we were not teenagers
[Applause]
thank you
everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
together together
hey William how you doing
I love it yeah
you announcement for the three words
I think I went one word over as well
amazing thank you very much most
important what does it mean to both of
you
that's the epitome of glamor and you
know it's been a busy Film Festival so I
think I'm for it just finishes up nicely
built for an amazing course
excuse me
[Music]
that means what it was like okay
they're actually our Cupids I don't know
if anyone knows it's not really met at
Aston Martin event so it feels very it
was very happy to be uh
yesterday
wow I mean what a piece of equipment
right oh it's beautiful we met with the
designers
and intricate details that went into the
designs
with the brand itself
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
a lot of people
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
can you tell me a little bit about how
important you feel an organization like
amphorus and the work that they do I
think it's desperately important and
having lost family members to a region
HIV have been affected by HIV and my own
family you know it's hit home
um and my family had some support at
that time so the thought that anyone
would be in this situation without
support
that's fine I'll tell you when you see
the progressed
and I hope that one day we will meet
yeah thank you by nobody
what do you think about the program what
are you hopeful for the people I'm
hopeful that we will get to that point
where we do we'll no longer need this
and we can hopefully take this same
template the same energy and apply it to
something else and some other great
cause that needs um needs a
amplification needs understanding a
diffusing of all the politicizing of it
and really just someone with a medical
condition being helped period yeah
I lost two teams I lost my favorite
cousin Tina and I lost
our Queen team our icon she means
everything
[Music]
why not you know why not we got to bring
some money for a good cause and Tim I'm
sorry and Tina Turner just passed what
are your thoughts on
you know I'm sad about it um but God
bless her she lived the life she gave us
everything we would want and more if
anything we should just celebrate her be
thankful be grateful and continue to
share the light and the love that she
did perfect thank you
[Music]
oh God
hey bro
[Music]
are
uh glasses
you got the dance Walk
you're welcome thank you
as well
left
and she just came back there
thank you
that's okay if not don't worry about it
I'll get one in the garage
at this point
oh they got it Brooke
thank you
thank you so much
thank you babe
it'll keep going until everybody's out
Haley do you want something else I only
just
thank you
in there waiting on Adam I know I'm here
um it's not here yet though
[Music]
excuse me
[Applause]
[Music]
one more time
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
this way
did you take a pic did you take any
pictures or video of me interviewing
Queen Latifah
even if I'm like half in it
oh yeah
I just wanted a picture of me
interviewing her that was all good I
know I forgot and I was like
somewhere
thank you though um I'll check if we
have you can see your face
[Applause]
I think so
other numbers
we have Adam
coming
up
here
this way
[Applause]
I'm like a hawk tonight
[Music]
thank you
right please
[Music]
thank you oh I'm so glad to make my
debut here I've never been to ampar
before and to be singing tonight is a
real honor talk to me about the
organization like I'm from the work that
they do it absolutely I mean AIDS
research and and all sorts of funds
raised to support people that are living
with HIV AIDS it's all important it
always has been important and there's
still areas where it's a serious serious
issue you know as a queer man myself
it's something that affected the last
generations of my community was so
violently so it's really lovely that
we're here tonight all in glamor raising
money for a good cause a music is
helping pave the weight once again yeah
in this industry and
absolutely and you know the Arts are
such a great way to open people's
Concepts so that they are more in the
spirit of helping I think it's a really
important thing on a lineup with
something like that it's like I mean
come on it's a big honor I mean the
whole lineup is great when I was told I
was like very flattered I was just
talking to Queen to keep a second ago
about the fact that we lost
I mean she was such an icon and a
Survivor and a voice like just as a
vocalist like just listening to what she
did with her voice there's no way to
describe it it's something that she
didn't even have a feeling she didn't
really even think about it
you know it was so real and wrong it's
very rock and roll definitely it's very
funny could I get you to say to this
camera
yeah
hey I'm Adam Lambert and welcome to
Amazon
television thank you I'll stand back
thank you
to perform for this event and what did
you feel you know I've always seen
footage and and photographs from this
event and I always thought wow that
looks very glamorous wouldn't that be
nice to go to the south of France and so
when I got the call I was thrilled I'm
very honored to be singing tonight for
this this cause and
um seeing amazing people on the carpet
and and beautiful fashion all in the
name of raising money for HIV AIDS
research and crisis management and
everything in between
strings I felt like everyone's dressed
up in these beautiful outfits let's do
something kind of highbrow
just been kind of in awe you know
driving around and walking on the beach
and it's beautiful really beautiful
well if I had the answer to that I think
you know it would be eradicated but you
know I think visibility and
verbalization I think when people talk
about things
um and they're they they you know bypass
the shame that surrounds it the more we
speak on these things and normalize them
the easier it is for other people to
feel the same way
yeah I can't wait
what did you think when you first heard
I was thrilled I mean I've seen footage
and photographs from this event for
years and I always thought you know well
that would be nice you know and so here
I am it is nice and niece is over there
thank you thanks guys he's performing he
needs to get those guys
foreign
is coming
Maybe
[Music]
thank you
but they're also ending cocktails for
dinner now